SeaWorld has launched a new ad campaign  true story now it's the first series of  ads they've done since the documentary  blackfish came out which was highly  critical of SeaWorld alleging that they  mistreat their orca whales  okay so SeaWorld trying to battle back  SeaWorld is hoping these new ads will  turn everything around for them we got  ahold of one take a look  my hope for people when they leave  SeaWorld that these magnificent  creatures touch them the way that  they've inspired and touched us  and to realize they carry  I'm going a SeaWorld now is that a  killer whale or Gerard Depardieu  [Applause]  very heavy French actor okay  you